[Music]
welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we're hosting webinars
every Tuesday
my name is cheetah and today I will be
talking about AI in France with UCP on
Intel you can ask questions any time and
we have folks from Intel and Googlers
who will be taking your questions let's
get started we will be talking about
value proposition of Intel Xeon and GCP
and how to configure your GCP
environment with Intel hardware and
software optimizations and tools to get
the best performance for your AI
application we will present to you some
of the work that we have been doing with
Google over the course of two years and
how we can bring these optimizations and
tools available and easy to use in GCP
so here's an agenda of the talk first we
will go over a brief overview of Intel
and AI our strategy and strengths we
will continue with talking about our
Xeon CPUs available in DCP then we talk
about how we get the best performance
for AI applications from tuning and
optimizing different frameworks to run
best on our hardware and lastly we talk
about our two plus years of
collaboration with Google cloud to make
this performance easily available to GCP
developers I'd like to start with a real
example of an AI customer and to
highlight the value that Intel brings to
AI this is showing the lifecycle of an
industrial defect detection project and
we are showing the breakdown of this
lifecycle in two different phases while
other projects will be different in time
break down the steps are typically the
same at the bottom
overall time to solution is the complete
AI journey including steps from
opportunity assessment to development
and deployment and ultimately evaluation
of the end result in the middle we zoom
in on the develop and deploy portion of
the overall solution which includes
sourcing data proof of concept
development in France deployment as well
as integration into a broader
application at the top we zoom in
further on the proof-of-concept
in itself where you can see that data
preparation took a majority of the
development time followed by training
the model and testing plus documentation
as you can see there's a lot that needs
to happen before and after the
compute-intensive part of the lifecycle
which we refer to as the core machine
learning and deep learning phase Intel
works with customers across the entire
AI lifecycle to speed up overall time to
solution it's important to think about
the overall flow of your data including
the data management and other headaches
and what would get you to do the
deployment faster rather than
accelerating one portion of your
solution at a premium now in order to
expand on this concept a little more
let's take a quick look at the multiple
approaches to get your data ready before
your deployment and development cycles a
key factor in deciding your approach is
where you land on the data spectrum is
your data coming from one source or many
is it structured or unstructured how
much volume are you dealing with is it
mission-critical or not is it streaming
live or batch who needs access to it
these are some of the questions they
should be asking before you start your
process of the deep learning journey
are there any regulatory requirements
depending on your answers to these
questions we would recommend different
approaches and different tools to
integrate store process manage and
analyze your data for example if you're
dealing with live streaming data that's
coming from multiple sensors you would
want to consider tools for unified high
throughput and low latency real-time
data ingestion the bottom line is there
are many different approaches to setup
your data and get your data ready for
your AI development and deployment and
Intel works for the vast ecosystem in
this area to optimize their solution to
run best on our latest Hardware
leveraging these optimizations will
provide the best performance for the
data prep cycle as well as little to no
overhead and headache for managing and
moving your data
now that if you talked about different
cycles before we get to the core machine
learning deep learning of your AI
application let's take a quick look at
intel's complete portfolio of software
and solution stacks that run on intel's
diverse portfolio of hardware products
with our software stack we target every
level of AI expertise and engagement
from library developers to data
scientists to app developers we also
have a rich catalog of solutions based
on internal and public use cases to
share with solution architects across
different segments to simplify the
things a bit I'd like to focus on a
handful of these tools today that most
applied to GCP developers let's start
with Intel Xeon processor which is the
foundation of our AI solutions
especially in GCP we will be talking
about some of the improvements in the
latest generation of Xeon CPU and how
that would translate to better
performance for your AI application
next is MK LD n n our open source deep
neural network functions for our CPU
library developers can use these
primitives to accelerate performance on
our Hardware then we focus on the next
layer of stack with Intel optimized
frameworks especially tensorflow for the
purpose of this presentation as well as
until distribution of Python and lastly
we will focus on our deep learning
development toolkit open vino which
makes it possible to run in fear ins
with optimize performance on a wide
variety of hardware backends using a
unified API Intel has been partnering
with Google for many years on their data
center infrastructure and since 2016 we
have been collaborating closely with GCP
on cloud solutions that run run on heart
a run on our hardware to summarize the
strategy for our engagements on AI there
are three pillars that we focus on first
is the product through our very close
collaboration with Google GCP was the
first cloud service provider to provide
access to our latest generation Xeon
scalable processor in their cloud
environment even months before general
market availability of our product
Google is always at the leading edge of
the technology and we continue to
collaborate to provide time to market
for our products for GCP developers the
second pillar of our strategy is working
on tools and libraries to enable maximum
performance from our hardware this work
as I explained earlier spans across
multiple layers of software from
primitives and libraries to unified
compilers and SDKs and optimized deep
learning and machine learning frameworks
and lastly we collaborate with DCP to
make these tools available and ready to
access easy to access in the DCP
environment for the for the developers
so let's talk a little bit about our
product Intel Xeon scalable product also
known as skylake
is the latest generation of Intel CPUs
available in GCP since first quarter of
2017
these processors increase the number of
CPU cores from previous generation which
translates to 50% larger VMS you can now
select skylake based VMS with up to 96 V
CPUs and memory as large as 1.4 terabyte
skylake also incorporates many
microarchitecture advancements including
significantly larger caches caches which
translates to applications being able to
store larger data structures closer to
the core if your data structure doesn't
fit on the core you have more memory
bandwidth to access the memory faster
and on the execution side skylake
decreases the instruction latencies of
many instructions and adds wider
execution at the same time cyclic
skylake implements the latest generation
of Intel vector instructions avx-512
which provides twice as wide as previous
generation vector in vector sizes and
can boost floating-point performance up
to 82% all of this translates to faster
BCP use and containers based on skylake
in GCE and G
as well as other GCP products as you
know one of the essentials behind
convolutional neural network modeling is
matrix multiplication in xeon cpus were
accelerating instructions to perform
these operations as efficiently as
possible
skylake today supports FP 32 vector
multiply and add instructions as well as
int 8 instructions next generation of
Intel Xeon processors offers our new vnn
eye instructions Rhiannon I stands for
vector neural network instructions and
includes hardware acceleration for n28
convolution instructions in next
generation of Intel Xeon processors
three AVX instructions to perform our
three AVX instructions to perform nth
eight operations are fused into one
providing speed-up due to consuming less
clock cycles we're working very closely
with framework developers to make these
instructions integrated into their
frameworks so that they can take
advantage of the performance boost that
these instructions bring to your
application so we talked about our new
instructions and all the goodness in the
hardware that our new products bring to
GCP however any hardware is only as good
as the software that runs on top of it
so in addition to providing the features
in our hardware we have been heavily
focused on software optimizations to
leverage all the features in our
hardware we have been engaged very
closely over the last few years with
different framework developers to
integrate our libraries and upstream or
optimizations here is an example of our
optimization work over the course of one
year and a half from July 2017 which is
when we launch skylake CPUs publicly
there has been about 5.4 X improvement
in inference performance solely from
software optimizations this is a
comparison on the same Intel hardware
and can speak to the power of our
optimizations from now till next year
when our next-generation xeon cpus will
be available publicly we're expecting in
france performance to roughly
due to the new hardware acceleration
instructions implementation and the
additional performance optimizations
this chart is based on resident 50
performance obviously for a less compute
bound workload where there are other
bottlenecks in the hardware the results
will be less pronounced but still very
significant now let's focus on tensor
flow for a bit and talk briefly about
the framework optimizations we spoke
earlier about our optimized deep neural
network libraries mkl DNN as i mentioned
is our open source math kernal library
for deep neural networks and the main
building block of our framework
optimizations MPL DNN is highly
optimized using sometimes very low level
as low as assembly code and the API has
been developed with feedback and
integration and interactions with major
framework owners the optimizations are
done at multiple layers first all the
primitives such as convolution matrix
multiplication and batch normalization
are rewritten to take advantage of the
latest wide vector instructions next the
different layers are parallelized to
allow for efficient use of all the
available course in the hardware and
lastly balanced use of prefetching cache
blocking techniques and data formats
that promotes spatial and temporal
locality are used to make data more
available when the execution units
needed in addition to using MTL DNN
primitives we use other techniques to
integrate into tensor flow there are
things that we do like layout
optimization replacing default tensor
flow operations fuse operations
propagating intermediate states and we
have our custom CPU pool allocator
which basically helps with avoiding
costly page misses and and page clears
we have been working with Google on
these optimizations for two plus years
and continue to collaborate to realize
the gains from the new instructions and
framework performance
now it is in addition to tensorflow and
other deep learning frameworks we have
been contributing our optimized
libraries to Python
we have accelerated numpy sci-fi and
scikit-learn with mkl DNN I'm sorry with
mkl with Intel MKL our optimizations are
available through Conda and anaconda
cloud for general public use and our
upstream back to main Python trunk if
you're interested to find out more on
Intel distribution of Python and some
performance proof lines we have a good
write-up on this on our Intel website
software website I think there's a link
on this slide that you can refer to and
here is just an example of using the
psyche of learn library in GCP
environment to achieve significant
performance speed up this is using a
k-means clustering algorithm you can see
gains of up to 23 X faster for using the
Intel scikit-learn versus a stock as I
could learn library from Python and this
is run on it on GCP on a 96 V CPU
skylake instance
now that we talked about some of the
Intel optimized libraries and frameworks
I'd like to spend some time to tell you
a little bit about our collaboration
with Google cloud to bring the
performance of these optimizations to
you as an easily accessible asset in GCP
we have created dr. images with both
Intel optimized tensorflow and Intel
distribution of Python on docker hub and
github there's a link for these to
access these Dockers basically these
will bring all the goodness of our
software as a one-click docker download
for your image so you can use these to
develop faster and and more efficiently
we've also been working with Google to
make Intel distribution of Python as
well as some Intel performance libraries
available on Google container registry
the Intel performance libraries include
libraries like Intel math kernal library
Intel threading building blocks into MPI
IPP and data and I like analytics
acceleration library for you to be able
to use these libraries on your VMs you
need to make sure that your runtime is
actually available for these libraries
and there's good instructions on the on
the link on the website where you can
download these basically download the
runtimes and make them available in your
in your VM instances in addition to
containers with Intel optimized
libraries we have been collaborating
with Google to create optimized virtual
machine images in addition to ease of
use and deployment these images
guarantee that the developers are always
leveraging the latest version of the
optimizations through these images
recently GCP released two Intel
optimized VM images one with tensorflow
one 12.0 using the latest MK LD n n and
m KL libraries and another one with
intel optimizations for three Python
libraries numpy Saipan scikit-learn
these images automate setting up the
environment variables with the right
variables and are available through
google cloud marketplace GCE OS images
and command-line interface I would like
to spend a little bit of time to walk
you through how to get started with
selecting the right platform in GCP and
accessing the optimized images to start
off in Google compute engine when you're
creating an instance go to the CPU
platform pulldown menu and select Intel
skylake or later to guarantee that your
application will leverage will leverage
the latest hardware enhancements we
talked earlier about the advantages of
skylake over previous generation CPU and
I'm glad to mention that in terms of
availability skylake is now available in
16 out of 17 TCP regions if you're not
using the council console you can use
the min cpu platform flag and G cloud
shell to select your CPU and any of the
sixteen zones with skylake availability
you can set the flag to Intel skylake
when you create your VM to guarantee
running on skylake as we discussed
earlier the main premise of the VM
images is to make into optimizations and
tools easily available to DCP developers
one of the ways for accessing the VM
images with Intel optimized tensorflow
and/or Intel optimized Python is to you
is to use google cloud marketplace in
your Google Cloud console environment
click on marketplace and look for deep
learning VM images with one click you
will be able to deploy these images on
your VM you can also access these images
on GCE if you're looking for more
control when you're setting up your VM
deployed these optimized OS images but
by changing the boot disk and selecting
one of the Intel optimized images to
take full advantage of the optimizations
on the latest architecture make sure
that you select your CPU platform as
Intel skylake or later while doing this
and if you're using google call
command-line interface you can launch
the VM images using the following
command line options set the image
family variable to one of the intro
specific image types at the time you are
creating your instance you can also set
the min CPU platform variable to the
latest Intel CPU skylake now I'd like to
talk to you about the art tool kit so we
talked about the libraries we talked
about different layers of software stack
and be focused on the on the libraries
and frameworks so far and I'd like to
talk to you a little bit about our tool
kit and what what helps you develop for
Intel hardware so our latest project
with Google Cloud has been on cube flow
pipeline and we've been working on
integrating part of our development
toolkit into the cube flow pipeline
earlier we talked a little bit about our
software toolkit with a common API
across different Intel hardware this
software toolkit is known as open vino
which stands for open visual and France
and neural net optimization open veena
has three main components first is a
deep learning deployment kit or dl/dt
the second one is a an open CV and media
SDK used for traditional vision and
video processing and third is a
collection of pre trained models and
tutorials
in summary open vino provides a unified
programming model across Hardware is
optimized for performance and memory
footprint is extensible for custom
workloads provides broad operating
system support it's self-contained for a
simple out-of-the-box experience and is
open source for the community to
contribute and enhance the components
that we will focus on today are
basically the dl/dt which offers a model
optimizer and an
engine with unified api's across
different Intel hardware so Intel and
Google are partnering to bring the
performance and ease of use of dl/dt to
GCP developers by adding dl/dt
containers to the D to the cube flow
pipeline suppose your data scientists
creating an end-to-end solution based on
some medical images your work can be
done through multiple different
containers the data ingestion data
transformation and data validation
containers facilitate reading the data
transforming the data to the expected
format and validating the data is
useable as usable and properly labeled
this data is passed to the trainer
container the output is a trained model
that is passed to the model validation
container to ensure the model is ready
for deployment or serving the Train
model is then used for serving by your
end party the way open vino is
integrated into this flow is that the
Train model is fed to the dl/dt model
optimizer the model optimizer generates
optimized IR and then the optimized IR
is fed into the serving with dl/dt
container basically using the inference
engine to run this as efficiently as
possible on the Intel hardware back-end
so here we have some examples of
integrating cube flow pipelines with
open open vino containers in the links
provided here we have the two examples
and we invite you to go ahead and try
these examples and just go through the
flow of integrating these containers
into the cube flow pipeline you can
learn more about open vino and its
benefits using the link at the bottom
also my colleagues are going to deliver
a webinar on introduction to AI
pipelines and Intel open B no
integration that I highly encourage you
to watch to learn more
so just to wrap up here are some
resources for more information on Intel
resources for AI for AI developers Intel
AI Academy is the best place to start to
learn more about into's assets and tools
AI builder solution library is a great
one-stop shop to find Intel AI
technology-based solutions for different
verticals and Intel's landing page on GC
P is a great starting point to learn
more about Intel technologies enabled in
GCP with that I would like to thank you
again for the opportunity of introducing
some of our AI technologies in GCP
please stay tuned for our live Q&A my
colleague Bhanu will join to help answer
some questions we will be back in less
than a minute
you
so I have bond here with me and we're
gonna try to answer as many questions
from the audience as we can we've
collected some questions while I was
talking and bonham so here's a question
asking what are some of the examples of
customers using Zeon free I that's a
it's a really good question so on for AI
we have a lot of customers who use our
Xeon processors for both machine
learning and deep learning workloads
specifically in deep learning for AI we
have two different types of workloads
for inference and for training that we
support our customers use Zeon scalable
processors our skylake CPUs for
streaming inference and batch entrants
one example for streaming inference that
we recently talked about was tabula it
is a recommendation engine that does web
serving for web serving applications and
they use our Xeon CPUs for bringing the
data in to stream it in and then do
real-time entrance on the data and they
offer around like three hundred and
sixty billion recommendations four
billion unique users every month so that
is one example of streaming insurance
and then for batch entrance we have
customers like GE healthcare that uses
Xeon CPUs specifically for image
recognition workloads and their workload
is on drug you know like more like CT
scan and pharmaceutical related and they
use the Xeon CPUs for batch entrance
which is when they have a database and
collected set of data and they use that
to run inference in in large batch sizes
and they have realized you know
tremendous amount of performance
improvements by going to the Xeon CPUs
and then we also have training workloads
we have companies like Novartis in the
pharmaceutical industry doing high
content screening which is basically
looking
a really large image sizes if you look
at some of the benchmarks that we use
for example like last night 50 they use
an image net database and that is a
smaller set of images but in real life
our customers use much larger image
sizes and they ng and you know Novartis
is one of the examples on training where
they have achieved improvements in the
time to train and throughput using the
Xeon CPUs so those are some of the
examples of our customers using the Xeon
for air right I think the next question
kind of leads to that as well the next
question is can we also run training on
Xeon so we've been talking about in
France on how to set it up and how to
use it and on Xeon and GCP do we have
any examples of customers running
training on Xeon is it is it doable
right yeah that's a good question so
Xeon CPUs are multi-purpose
CPUs which are used for a wide variety
of workloads and deep learning is a
subset of one of those workloads that is
very important to Intel and our
customers as part of that you can run
training on the Xeon CPUs one of the
examples I alluded to was Novartis but
there are a few others that I can touch
upon for example in the convergence of
HPC and AI we have you know workloads
that run for our customers on a
tremendously large data bases one of the
examples is recently we talked about in
the supercomputing 2018 conference on
how gen Z a French Research Institute
use Xeon CPUs to scale training across
multiple CPUs almost 128 nodes
achieving a higher level of scaling
efficiency and getting to the accuracy
that is needed so that is one of the
examples of how you can run training on
Zeon's do you want to yeah actually as a
matter of fact in GC p we've had a we've
had a few customers that are doing
training on Z on their applications go
across from visual effects to satellite
imagery
the cart lab is one of them who has
publicly you know announced that they're
doing training on Zeon and there are a
couple couple others that that are
actually doing this in GCP environment
okay yeah one other example that came to
my mind was also like CERN that they you
know the they use the Large Hadron
Collider to and they have a massive
amount of data set that they collect and
they run like high-performance computing
like Monte Carlo simulations to do that
and they use Xeon CPUs to do distributed
training across those 256 nodes and we
showed in one example on 3d gun which is
generative adversarial networks and that
showing scaling efficiency across
multiple Xeon nodes as well ok great so
let's see again I can ask you the next
one then can we get access to deep
learning boost on our B and an eye on
GCP ok so that that's a that's a good
one so deep learning boost and BN and I
instructions are available in our next
generation Intel Xeon CPUs we're
actually shipping samples to our
customers towards the end of this year
when it's gonna be available in GCP is
really a question for GCP reps so i
really encourage you to be in touch with
your GCP reps in order to find out their
timelines on when they're gonna make
this available in their platform so I
have one free unit now
actually let's go to the last one first
because I want you to answer that one
and then if you have time we'll come
back to the previous one so what
different topologies and frameworks are
optimized for Intel hardware that's a
good one so you did touch upon like the
Intel portfolio slide and showed like
the different frameworks that we
optimized for so to summarise beyond do
like tensorflow
primarily for framework optimizations
but in addition to that we also do like
MX net cafe 2 and then PI torch and
paddle paddle as some of the examples of
the frameworks that we optimized for in
terms of 2
apologies we do a wide variety of
topologies and they are very related to
the use cases that our customers are
applying for for example we run image
recognition which was like the rest 950
inception these three examples we do
object detection which is like Yolo is
an example of that we do image
segmentation there we are looking at
specific segments of an image and that's
like masks are CNN they also do like
language translation which is the neural
machine translation workloads and then
some of the other ones that come to mind
are like text-to-speech they've met is a
good example of text-to-speech workload
and even recommender systems for example
like widened deep or neural
collaborative filtering so it's
basically a huge range of topologies
that we optimize for on these different
frameworks okay so not only libraries
and primitives also do frameworks and
that's the part that we also work with
different topologies into different
workloads right and I think probably we
have time for one more question what is
the benefit of Intel up to my software
and why do I need it that's a good
question I can start and then you can
add - so what today has been talking
about to you today has been about why
you know like what are the different
things we can do but why do we need to
do it right for example the hardware
that we build like skylake has an
avx-512 instructions and our
next-generation Xeon CPU will have like
the vni instructions in order to get the
performance out of these instructions
you need the libraries that are
developed on top of it to use these
instructions and then once you have
those libraries develop you need like
the framework to call these libraries so
that is why we say that you need the
latest optimized software on on ental
hardware in order to get the best
performance do you want to give like a
GCP it's pretty much the same thing okay
okay as long as you have
works the technologies available make
sure that you're using them make sure
you're using the latest and greatest of
the hardware and the software give it a
try and your performance is going to see
the advantage and the boost right so I
think we dad we're gonna close stay
tuned for the next session introducing
AI hub the one-stop catalog for
everything AI thank you thank you
[Music]